FORWARD IN THE TROUBLED
REGION, BRET?
>> Bret: GREG PALKOT IN
LONDON.
THANK YOU.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE COMEY
INTERVIEW AND WHAT WE DID
NOT SEE LAST NIGHT.
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME JOINS US.
GOOD EVENING, BRIT.
FIRST YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
COMEY ROLLOUT AND THAT
INTERVIEW WITH GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS.
>> IT SEEMS TO ME, BRET,
THAT COMEY COMES ACROSS AS A
MAN NO AT LEAST IN HIS OWN
EYES TRIED VERY HARD TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AND FAILED.
I MEAN, HE WOULDN'T SAY THAT
HE FAILED, BUT YOU LOOK AT
THE MISTAKES HE MADE OVER
TIME, DECIDING THE HILLARY
CLINTON INVESTIGATION FOR
ONE.
HE VERY QUITE LIKELY REACHED
THE WRONG DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER SHE SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED.
HIS ARGUMENT FLIES IN THE
FACE OF THE STATUTE
GOVERNING THE HANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THEN HE PROCEEDED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT, USURPING THE
ROLE OF DECISION AND THE
GENERAL.
THEN HE PROCEEDED TO COME
OUT AND SAY THAT THE
INVESTIGATION HAD BEEN
REOPENED, WHICH HE SHOULD
NOT HAVE DONE IN MY VIEW AND
I SAID SO AT THE TIME.
AND THEN THAT LEAD HIM WHEN
THE INVESTIGATION HAD BEEN
FINISHED AGAIN COME OUT
LATER ON AND SAFE THAT.
ALL OF WHICH HAD THE EFFECT
ON THE ELECTION CAMPAIGN
SOMETHING COMEY SAID IT MADE
HIM BE SICK TO HIS STOMACH
THINK HE MIGHT BE DOING BUT
I DID IT HE COMES ACROSS TO
ME ALMOST AS A SAD FIGURE.
AND THIS -- AND THESE
ATTACKS ON THE MAN WHO FIRED
HIM ARE UNSEEMLY.
I WOULD SAY THE PRESIDENT'S
RESPONSES ARE EQUALLY SO,
MAYBE EVEN MORE.
SO BUT THESE ALL ADD UP TO A
CATALOG OF MISTAKES BY COMEY
WHICH ARE NO WAY, I THINK HE
IS NO WAY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEM BY THESE INTERVIEWS OR
THIS BOOK.
>> Bret: THE ABC INTERVIEW
APPEARED HEAVILY EDITED.
WE KNOW IT WAS SOME FIVE
HOURS OF INTERVIEW BETWEEN
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS AND
JAMES COMEY.
SOME OF IT ON THE EDIT ROOM
FLOOR.
ONE PART FROM THE TRANSCRIPT
COMEY SAYS WE HAVE THE
PROBLEM THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
HAD TWICE PUBLICLY,
BASICALLY SAID THERE'S NO
THERE THERE.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH ON FOX
IN AN INTERVIEW ON 60
MINUTES BOTH TIMES HE SAID
THAT SO THAT'S JIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
STEPHANOPOULOS SAID DID THAT
SURPRISE YOU.
COMEY SAID IT REALLY DID
SURPRISE ME.
IS HE A SMART MAN AND
LAWYER.
IT SURPRISED ME.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT.
IT WAS INAPPROPRIATE.
THAT DID NOT MAKE IT INTO
THE INTERVIEW.
>> Bret: NO.
YOU WOULD THINK IN AN
INTERVIEW SO HEAVILY LACED
WITH HIS ATTACKS ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
UNUNDOUBTEDLY NEWS WORTHY
AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED.
THE FACT HE WAS CRITICAL OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA IN A MATTER
RELATED TO THE HILLARY
CLINTON INVESTIGATION WOULD
HAVE MADE IT TO THE
INTERVIEW.
I'M SURPRISED IT DIDN'T.
IT SHOULD HAVE.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE
SYRIA SITUATION?
YOU HAD THE -- U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED
NATIONS YESTERDAY ON A
SUNDAY SHOW SAYING THAT
SANCTIONS WERE COMING AS
SOON AS TODAY FROM THE
TREASURY SECRETARY ON
RUSSIA.
AND THEN TODAY THE WHITE
HOUSE KIND OF WALKING THAT
BACK.
SAYING THEY ARE CONSIDERING
WHAT TO DO.
IN THE WAKE OF ALL OF THIS,
TO HAVE THAT KIND OF BACK
AND FORTH TODAY?
>> WELL, IT'S EMBARRASSING,
IN LIGHT OF WHAT I THINK HAS
BEEN WIDELY REGARDED AS A
SUCCESSFUL MISSION IN SYRIA.
AND TO HAVE THIS APPARENT
CONTRADICTION.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S A
CONTRADICTION IN TERMS OF
THE POLICY ITSELF.
OR WHETHER IT'S SIMPLY A
MATTER OF TIMING.
I GUESS WE WILL SOON SEE.
AS FOR THE MISSION ITSELF,
WE KEEP HEARING, BRET, FROM
CRITICS OF IT THAT WHAT WE
REALLY NEED HERE IS A
BROADER SYRIA POLICY.
AND THAT -- AND THAT THE
BOMBING RUNS ARE NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR THAT I WOULD
BE INCLINED TO DISAGREE WITH
THEM IN THIS SENSE, BRET.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S
AMBITIONS OR TENSIONS IN
SYRIA ARE QUITE LIMITED.
HE WANTS TO OBVIOUSLY FINISH
THE JOB AGAINST ISIS AND GET
OUR FORCES OUT OF THERE ONCE
THAT'S DONE.
I THINK HE WANTS TO DETER
THE FURTHER USE OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS THAT HE IS NOT
TRYING TO SIDE IN THE CIVIL
WAR AGAINST ASSAD
PARTICULARLY.
HE IS SAYING THESE WEAPONS
CROSS A LINE.
A LINE ONCE DRAWN BY HIS
PREDECESSOR WHO DID NOTHING
WHEN IT WAS CROSSED.
TWO THINGS, DEFEAT ISIS AND
SEE TER THE USE OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
THAT MAY NOT BE THE RIGHT
POLICY BUT THAT'S WHAT IT IS